bonjour je suis Madame maldonat gérante
de la société beauty perfect institut
citron vert c'est une franchise
implantée à l'aile de la Réunion depuis
deux ans nous sommes un institut 10
nouvelles générations nous sommes sans
rendez-vous avec de l'argent amplitude
horaire donc nous sommes ouverts du
lundi matin au samedi donc du lundi au
vendredi nous faisons 10h 19h et le
samedi 9h 18h toujours non-stop en
termes de prestation nous faisons deux
épilations épilation femme et homme donc
tout ce qui est manucure pédicure vernis
semi permanent soin du visage nous
proposons des formules d'abonnement qui
peuvent qui vous permettent de diminuer
30% votre budget annuel actuellement
nous sommes 5 avec en effectif avec un
contrat d'apprentissage
je suis à la recherche actuellement
d'une esthéticienne confirmée le poste à
pouvoir être est situé à Saint-Denis
donc nous recherchons une personne
titulaire d'un CAP plus deux ans
d'expérience ou d'un BP PLUS 6 mois
d'expérience ce poste demande une
certaine polyvalence puisque vous
passerez de aussi bien d'une épilation à
de l'onglerie à du soin du visage nous
recherchons une personne jeune dynamique
qui puisse qui est le sens d'équipe qui
puisse s'intégrer très rapidement et
apprendre et qui est des envies
d'évolution vous êtes souriante motivé
notre proposition vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas à vous présenter un
institut citron vert